then this is what i don't like the news
does the news does this [ __ ] they say oh
a lot of elderly people are dying from
it and a baby has it
that's what they always do
but what do we know about this baby
because they never show the baby is this
baby a legit baby
is he small and incapable or is this a
freaking baby that's you know he was
with the union for a few years and then
he jumped over to picket lines and he's
been smoking he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about himself he's got two other little
babies of his own who is this baby
because don't just hook me with the baby
line oh a baby has it
who is he
i want real information
it's just such a crazy time for
something like this because who believes
the news